there's a quote in which he said if you
don't try to uncover what is unseen and
understand its nature you will be ill
prepared to lead the stuff that we know
we know like that's one piece but the
stuff that we don't know that we don't
know that's gigantic it's huge how do
you actually operate in a world in which
there's so many possibilities of things
in this case you're actually working off
of the way you think about change your
opportunity or your value system you
don't know what's going to happen I just
accept it okay I don't know a lot that's
why I can't be right a lot and if I can
accept the fact that I really don't know
then I think it opens us up to say oh I
really do need help than anybody at any
level